officer
okay what's going on I don't care how do
we fix this
because you got it's gonna get fucking
killed is what's gonna happen and so are
you for driving like this
what the fuck do we do I have fucking no
idea
you guys
foreign
or in that backyard
you know how to Wrangle a cow
yeah
easy easy
oh he's going right through those bushes
oh
I'm stuck now
that thing is going to freak out
well I'm glad you're enjoying yourself
as a dispatcher in Skokie and who um
wears a cow talk that tripped over on
the highway and there were cows
everywhere yeah
[Music]
I don't know dispatch can you uh repeat
the address they put up
this thing's corner
foreign
what street are we on
do you want to go find the idiots with
the truck and see if they can come get
their God
no it's it's it's a bunch of jagoff kids
yeah it was a senior prank gone wrong
College Prep
no the Northridge watch yourself because
it's back into a corner and it's
breathing very heavy so
nothing
I I called Sarge I was like I'm a city
boy you got any uh
I want to strangle these
um
no
they were probably all over the place
right now it's audacious problem I'm
just standing by until uh day shift
figures out what the fucking coming here
no hi kitty kitty kitty kitty kitty
yeah kitty kitty kitty kitty
are those little stupid fucking kids
what are we gonna do they have like a
thing to Wrangle them this is just do
they yeah you saw it yeah they were
running around with it on Ballad and I'm
like where the fuck I don't know
[Music]
I feel like all these 18 year olds need
a disorderly conduct ticket that's what
I think now you got three cops after we
told you guys to go home
and this is the football I gotta deal
with because y'all thought this was a
funny prank
what if that thing would have got hit on
the goddamn Road who's how is it
it's not so funny anymore is it right
action has consequences and you're all
18. so maybe I should take you all in
fingerprint every single one of you and
you all start your fucking College off
with a goddamn record yeah how about
that so where is the person that's gonna
get this God cow out of here
from where
I'm so fuck ing irritated right now
oh
and we're back off no how about let's
not piss it off because I'm not fucking
explaining to your God's parents why
somebody died today
and just remember everything that's
broken over there is coming out of one
of your guys's pocket because this is
somebody's fucking house this isn't a
goddamn Farm
so nobody knows how to actually deal
with this correct
because now you're pissing off an animal
and now it's causing property damage
so we're gonna have to probably get Cook
County out here to put it down so it
doesn't kill somebody all this over a
fucking prank guys where did we get the
cow from
Wisconsin
huh Wisconsin
so we don't even have somebody that can
handle the car appropriately
sorry I'm trying to figure out we have
this thing uh all these idiots that uh
took this cow from Wisconsin don't know
how to handle with it now it's cornered
and it's getting really pissed off so
I'm trying to figure out what our best
move is before it attacks somebody
it is but the issue is that it's in
somebody's backyard and it's uh stuck
literally between a rock and a hard
place there's a fence uh a little
and and Evergreens and the things
aggravated it's breathing heavy and it's
already charged as somebody wants
so officer what uh if it came down to
are we able just to put it down before
it ends up hurting anyone else to bring
any more property damage to the netbeat
reliable option so you want me to kill
something to stop property damage no no
man make that make sense any type of
like hurting someone else and how am I
supposed to know that
I mean I I guess I'm not a farmer I
don't deal with wild animals I
understand that so again now I'm liable
when I pull my firearm out to protect
somebody else's like you see the pickle
that you can put me in
yeah yeah
yeah because this could be all over the
news I fucking guarantee it will be and
I'll probably get fired for swearing so
much but I'm so irritated with how
fucking stupid you guys are when I told
you to go the fuck home
but no I don't remember who said it but
somebody said well we're in this deep
well congratulations here you go
I hope the Village of Niles charges you
the overtime for me and him and
everybody else that's going to come out
here and deal with the situation on top
of fixing their backyard their shed
whatever they have on the side of the
shed hell you should probably get
charged for Public Works clean up all
the shit up and down Greenwood
you guys think that this is a big
fucking game
it's a lot of money you're costing the
town all over a stupid prank
and I guarantee you if I arrest all of
you which I will gladly do because
that's how irritated I am right now
you're not getting into college with
your disorderly conducts
actions have consequences gentlemen
we're not 16 anymore
I thought we would have learned by how
nice we were telling you at 3am to go
home but of course you guys had to show
us how big and bad you are how good you
are how much you had this so planned out
what if that thing would have got hit
what if somebody else got hit where is
it can you see
can you see it's back there and
we can keep it back there let's not even
go over there it's in the other yard no
it's in this yard this yard's completely
fenced in okay in that corner okay so
it's wedged back there
but
all right
I just talked to somebody from the farm
they said leave it alone we'll leave it
right where it's at it's not bothering
anybody it's not hurting anything and
they'll come and get it
but we're not gonna play Cowboy right
here
okay
yeah 90 minutes is it really yeah
hopefully it soon
back there for like three minutes and
then I got it where did it come out from
the shovel isn't the red handle and the
bushes on the left side it came out that
way that's the way a game went into but
then you guys have put the chair there
to kind of stop it well no it ran
through the chair put it over there just
kind of piling stuff behind it all right
I mean I know it came in that trailer so
I know originally
School prank right I get it yeah and we
thought that we handled it right right
clearly that didn't happen so they came
after so they get after we handled that
we left
when they came back progressively and we
got to call them there's a loose cow
all right
so they said if it's calm it'll
generally stay calm
and we'll leave it right where it's at
Okay so
let's take this call back there if it is
called
before it was dream like it was freaking
the fuck out well now maybe resigned to
its feet
like this is my life now I'm stuck
so
well we're not going to do anything to
agitate it if there's fences on both
sides and it's kind of behind that Barn
all right
let's all just
step back out of here
we fuck these people they know what's
going on in their backyard I tried
knocking it out they're either yeah
that's not how I wanted to start my day
no
later beginning a call from a Wisconsin
farm claiming that this is stolen right
no sir
so whose is this
what world class special
s okay
what was the plan afterwards
well we're gonna give it to someone with
a fine
oh they got a hold of somebody at Wagner
Farm they're sending somebody who will
come and collect it
but it's going to be 90 minutes 90
minutes
they're like if it's contained and calm
just leave it alone stay away from it
and please don't put it down
so what enforcement action are we taking
on this
are we just going to chalk us up to kids
being stupid at 18 and call it a night
to apologize it's it's behind a little
shed back there
so how many
they're saying that everybody's in the
entire class came together too yeah but
these are all the people that are here
so yeah I got four plus
five six
seven eight nine ten people are here
for certain kind of sounds appropriate
for all 10 of them yeah
it's the village POS
I prefer to arrest all of them in the
wild criminal record they put me through
today I understand
this was a definite group effort and
then I think they're all chemical
producers
well I have the list of everybody else
that was there on my original report
yeah granted they're not here for this
you can go home
[Music]
yeah I don't feel it's fair just to
punish a ton of people that are here but
obviously if they're not here we can't
really do it other than the first what
we might do is
here and the reason I did the
investigation he's recording him
everybody
well that's what they said but like I
said it pisses me off that I told all of
them to go home and they basically said
you we're still doing this we're
invested
after having all the 17 year olds get
curfew tickets
why are all the kids here
because they let it out so now they're
trying to fix their mistake
before school starts so they're not even
going to get there to go surprise
there's a chicken in your room because
we're too busy chasing a cow through the
village denials
oh what time does school start I should
have Regal rate of them all for truancy
on top of it it's just
really get this train going excuse me
oh wow what would you like us to do Ron
we know just as much as you do about
wild animals
the one kid asked can you shoot them
like
unbelievable these kids just they just
they just don't they just don't get it
and these people still have an answer
huh
I don't think they're home I've knocked
on the front door back on the back door
oh These people aren't even here it's a
hot water I don't think so
[Applause]
and uh
thank you
[Music]
oh I see you okay
assistant
I'm happy
I think if I get a rope I can get a hold
of it
so they've got a little bit out of there
yeah okay
which one you want to go in from yeah
I mean it came in that hit backwards
whatever way I go it's gonna try to go
the other way and jam out of there so
I'm gonna go the other way and see if I
can get close to it without it getting
it running out yeah what do you mean
from us yeah
I mean if it's hopefully not then if it
starts to go forward
I mean we just don't want it to get
loose I know yeah that's
well if we could just keep it in the
yard here that would be ideal so do you
want us to do that
you know they're not difficult they just
uh
well I I'm sure it's under some distress
yeah for sure for sure
first
is there a fence
yeah yeah there's a fence on the other
side there it's chain link
[Music]
holy smokes you all right yeah
comes with me
are you all right we got the Rope on it
though right that
one
foreign
[Music]
59 for 140.
000 uh
foreign
tough one
should be nice do you want me to notify
Park original
yeah they're aware
kind of back behind on the top side of
the Tiger
Park
we're in the Gold Ridge Neighborhood
near 1022.
[Music]
foreign
it's now behind like uh 12 20.
[Laughter]
it's going back eastbound towards
Cumberland
or by like we'll try and get back to my
car
yeah it's not a usual call when uh I
entered work I was about to work out and
the sergeant right there he says uh
favorite cowboy hat on we have a cow to
catch and I chuckled and then I left and
then later was told that no no he was
serious
get to work you know they did have
access to the school
um is there anything
[Music]
come on
all right Kevin
um all right so so we have a a type of a
farm company that's out here trying to
help us with the cow
if I I mean do you want me to tell him
that there's a pig also that could be uh
like that he could take or no
and then and then just one more thing
too if you want once we're done
investigating just think about it talk
to Neil as far as trespassing or any
type of um uh if you want us to push any
type of citation to you know to some of
the kids just let me know
that's something for you to think about
though
all right
you hear me
okay perfect yeah I'll I'll let you go
bye
I got nothing for you my man
I mean they're still you know
everybody is getting four tickets
okay
now these four tickets are mandatory
court appearance however your Saving
Grace is that once again I'm a nice guy
and I wrote These on ordinance tickets
so it doesn't fuck up your whole life
because the disorderly conduct charges a
misdemeanor
okay we could have went after you for
animal cruelty because that animal was
not being treated appropriately but
instead you're getting charged with
sorely conduct you're getting charged
with having a species of animal that is
not allowed in the Village of Niles a
nuisance animal not cleaning up after
said protected species of animal and
you're getting uh
yep that's it and your disorderly
conduct tickets okay so like I said
you're gonna have to go to the Niles
Police Department you're gonna have to
ask for a court date okay do that sooner
than later so that you can all get on
the same court Peak and I'll go in front
of the our village attorney I need four
signatures from you okay you will get a
copy of all of these well actually make
sure that's you
because I got both ears in my hand
yep so to sign across them it's not
under Michigan it's just saying that
I've informed you that you need to go to
the Niles police station and get you a
court date I get it
prank gone wrong it happens but you know
just use this as a learning moment and
like I said you're getting off easy with
it not going on your permanent record so
let's just use that as The Silver Lining
and all of this okay how's Mom getting
to work if it's almost eight o'clock and
you're here
I'm just kidding stay out of trouble
guys okay thank you so much all right
I just want to let you know this I was
young ones too you're going to college
college campus police still can go on
your permanent record I'm not saying
you're bad kids it's a bad prank gone
wrong it happens I just want you to look
at the bigger picture now you're not 16
17 where this magically disappears
you get screwed up at College that's on
you guys okay so all your driver's
license are in here as well I got one
pen if you can just sign one of the
set of copies there
those are all 18 you're adults you make
grown man decisions
so you know I was hoping that
I don't know who said it I don't think
it's personal but I literally told
somebody who was carrying the chicken
coop right in front of me I'm like
really you guys are still gonna do this
after you guys got caught doing what
you're doing and they said we're in too
deep
okay well here we are so again there's
it is what it is and like I said I'm not
gonna repeat you guys up about it okay
so but no you guys are 18. don't call
Mommy and Daddy and you can't tell them
but I'm not going to because you have a
court date to go to if you don't go to
that court date you get in trouble you
get a warrant for your arrest not mommy
and daddy anymore because
they're no longer responsible for you
it might take care of you but
technically by law once you're 18 that's
why you guys didn't get citations the
first time like everybody else that was
with you
because everyone who was under 17 or
under 18 they all got written for curfew
they can't be out
so all right guys so just keep your
heads on straight take the Subscribe man
it's a learning experience but
let's just uh look forward from here
okay
um and to your point if you really are
interested later on today if you want to
call the police department and tell them
that you were the owner of the cow I'm
sure they'll know exactly who you are
and you could probably talk to somebody
that way well either way if you're that
interested I'm sure they'll have more
information then about it because like I
said they're still trying to Wrangle it
up so but you guys are huh I don't know
they're still trying to chase it so I
don't know where it ran off to and
everything else so
um
[Applause]
I mean could you be held criminally
liable for the damages and have to fix
them yes
obviously
um
but other than that no I think you guys
are you know pretty much
all right I don't want to say good but
um yes there's a chance that more things
could come of this depending on if it
runs out and damages somebody's car in
the middle of the street and they hit it
then you guys are gonna have to figure
that one out too because it's because of
something you guys created
okay so let's hope that uh this
gentleman is able to get his stuff
huh
who's who
I still have like four more handfuls of
tickets I gotta hand out oh my God
everybody that was here is getting them
wondering if he wanted to
um take custody of a pig yeah after the
this and then I said to the Northridge
prep team I said if you want charges
more charges as far as Criminal Trespass
um uh we can do that they're still
investigating so they'll probably look
at they gotta look at cameras still I
send them all the names because of the
fob obviously that's a massive issue of
keys are some yeah so I send them all
the names as far as the students that
we've encountered right past six hours
but so far that's what we got
so we still don't know who which teacher
gave up the file apparently that might
be a story uh they could have taken if
I'm
they could have accessed an area where
they keep an extra fob in the front but
they're going to be able to trace the
fob number as far as who scanned in and
hopefully be able to do that so
where's uh where is this
what's that where's this guy taking a
nap the it's kind of in the tree oh nice
yeah
it's been a long day that's a lot of
steps from Bruce it is let's see how
many I've got
the guy walked all the way from Bruce
he's like I don't know where you guys
were at I gave him my work cell just so
you know all right just in case we get a
2253 so far today there's not that many
roads
but I drove all the way back there and
then we chased them yeah we're actually
he ran and he followed not really cheap
um
I think we were joking this morning I
honestly thought you were joking we
laughed and then I just went to my
workout
I wasn't joking I wish I were
this apartment
I'm Gonna Cancel a presentation I got
going on just because Northridge is
involved but
I honestly I appreciate how Cooperative
you've been I know it's a situation to
be in but you know again same thing you
guys are taking it on the chin the best
that you can so like I said just make
the best of the worst situation and wait
dude do we know when he's coming to get
this thing or
no worries I just didn't know if you if
he was in a car or something hanging out
but is it in like no it's it's fine
we're just trying to figure out you know
so it's just not sitting there all day
and
no what's up man
these Marvel what you guys do in college
okay actions have consequences now that
we're adults all right all right thanks
for being cool guys I appreciate your
cooperation so to recap Northridge is
going to investigate the key fob you
guys are going to do your own internal
disciplinary measures for any students
that may be involved that was the
students that were given I gave the
students uh names to MN
yeah
okay as far as involvement goes so this
is a yearly thing right was that stable
put up by the administration or was that
something that was put up okay so
everything with the seniors and the
involvement with the administration I
wouldn't say involvement but the
awareness it was something that was
agreed upon is that correct
um up like said permission okay so
permission to and obviously everything
might have been downplayed right that
there was a cow or a calf they were
supposed to be in the front right not in
the schools but there was awareness from
the administration
um or notification that this would
happen and there was no I mean it wasn't
Administration it was one thing remember
yeah okay okay and that was that push to
you guys or pushed to you Neil
was a push to me or was it was it was it
no plan it was not but I trusted okay
guys all right so the faculty member uh
there was a a staff member that was
aware of the plans
um agreed upon right and the cow
obviously getting loose is not part of
it correct that's basically all I need
to know obviously if you're not going to
be and the size of the cow was not agree
it was not a correct okay so that was
that staff member and from what I
gathered there was a last minute switch
when they picked up the cow like what
they were gonna get cells were like not
what they actually got okay so there's
no other animals in school besides the
pig
okay so pigeons pigeons a pig you guys
are able to handle correct yeah okay so
there you guys don't need any of our
services
um and then as far as uh that uh that
that staff member do you mind giving the
name to that staff member yes yes okay
okay all right perfect
um listen I'm just gonna take down
information right I don't know what how
big this thing is going to get right
um but we do have to do the follow-up
media release and you know that's that's
what we're gonna do so if you have a
driver's license by chance okay
yeah so they may be reaching out and
this is the reason
uh foot injuries
yeah yeah so you have to be taken away
thank you
um
she was just checked on I don't think
it's nothing discharged from the
hospital I don't have a update on that
as far as that goes but
um
yeah she was taken there just to make
sure I don't think she's going back to
work today
um but she was trying to wrestle her
Corral
um uh still in seminary yeah perfect and
then best phone number for you this is
your key fob no okay all right so what's
that dude okay so you guys will still
investigate that together okay all right
well the the reality is they gave me
very little information okay so very
little information agreed upon for a
calf to be in the front was there any
ingredients to have anything inside the
school they were told specifically
nothing inside the school okay all right
so they were told uh just outside for a
small little baby calf right
um and then so that was agreed upon
outside right they told me they had
already purchased the calf and with
their hand motion it said this big okay
perfect
um and as far as anything else any Keys
fobs anything like that was never given
to any of the students uh for access to
your knowledge so you'll be able your it
will probably be able to see you yes
which Bob please deactivate that
uh so you don't have any follow-up uh
blowback and then uh you guys obviously
will be able to access your cameras yeah
um if you guys have any I think I'm
inside that already all right do you
have any questions for me yeah news
things like that I told I I don't know
if it might be the best I don't know if
it'd be a good idea they're gonna be
here they're just gonna shoot that
they're gonna get that pen yeah they'll
get the pen but as far as an on camera
interview they may be asking you
questions I I would avoid it's just my
personal experience uh if you want to
give something out to the parents right
as an Administration I've seen that
happen where
um just get get in front of it
um if they see their school especially
if they're like a sophomore junior they
don't know what's going on
um and that's why you know you guys are
cooperating with us we're cooperating
with you we're just trying to get that
cow in uh in the back of that trailer
um but besides that you know that's
that's pretty much yeah okay yeah we're
gonna go from there
um you guys have my number give me a
call and for me just I'm just I'm just
gonna be documenting as far as what you
said that it was agreed upon they have a
small playpen outside I took a picture
of it right there was never ingredients
uh for any animals to be inside or
obviously a larger cow I will put that
it was agreed upon for a calf to be
outside in that that little playpen
um a calf size you know like two foot
Dimension yeah I get that I yeah
honestly it's just more formality as far
as so I'm uh I shouldn't be expecting
citations I I can't say I'm not leaving
this investigation I'm more of the
liaison for you guys to kind of give you
updates as far as our media releases and
sounds good um uh but you know we
weren't planning for an officer to get
injured right now that is Park Ridge
yeah
um so is there anything we should do
about that Kevin should we reach out to
school I think they'll be reaching out
to us and then they may be giving you
guys a call or it could just be a uh
just something that they're gonna handle
internally and you guys may not receive
a call from Park Ridge so you know
that's something that you may not get
anything from but I would advise against
yeah you already let her know yeah we're
not gonna go because they they've asked
me they've asked officers it's just not
something unless you have something
prepared a documentation prepared it's
not something I would go into
um any other questions yeah uh Kevin so
uh are they if they show up here and
they start interviewing our students
should we be trying to manage our
students not getting yeah I honestly I
know this might be a day where you could
have students outside yeah I'm keeping
everybody inside yeah yeah until you
know that the media really allowed on
our property that's a gun I mean this is
private this is private property
outside yeah but not I told them they
cannot come outside
so you dictate who was allowed on your
property so I'm gonna go out there
um and kind of determine if uh you want
them I mean that's the only I think it's
fine if they take a picture of the hand
that gives context yeah yeah forget that
um no it does right right and that's I I
totally see your head uh on that
um yeah you're good yeah but interview
with students I will yeah I agree yeah
uh any other questions you guys have no
sorry about this yeah I'm real sorry
honestly it's not a call you get every
day so everybody wanted to jump on it so
you know I thought I honestly thought it
was a milk out I haven't seen a cow in
you know 10 years but it's a big boy
it's a big yeah big girls whatever you
want to say yeah I don't really know the
anatomy of cows but
um give me a call if you guys have any
questions yeah no I feel bad for The
Brokerage yeah I don't think it was
something she wasn't hitting the chest
as far as my as far as my knowledge it
wasn't something she was ran over I
think they were trying to either push it
towards
they just got the cop in custody that's
that's right so they just got the cow
just heard from thank goodness
that's great news it is it is
um any property damage then I think this
animal feces okay I'm gonna go into the
yard they were on Bruce which is uh
Cumberland
yeah can we do uh if I make
notifications I will ask um we haven't
been able to make notifications uh and
right since then it's just been sleeping
uh grab into uh
no no honestly it's something where
um
they just they just got it which is
obviously our main concern that nobody
or any Vehicles were damaged that's my
work so just in case
um
but they they just got it so I don't
know who purchased the cow it's not
hopefully it's not purchased illegal or
anything like that I don't think so I
don't think so right but it's going to
be at that uh the your partner with the
director of uh the guy that just left
with the golf yeah Joe Joe has uh the
name of the farm from Glenview okay that
is going to hold on hold on to it in
Glenview for the time our thought is Ben
hey seniors this is your decision you
gotta own this yeah you gotta make it
right and you got to deal with it yeah
so I so that cow it's not the schools
exactly that is between the farm and our
team I have no idea exactly did you
agree with that no I I I mean it's not
it's not yours right you guys never
throw in money uh for a cow purchase
um not not this way
to eat maybe all right right you guys
are eating well here uh no no uh I I
wouldn't that is something okay they'll
figure out custody and as far as what's
gonna be dealt with the cow as far as
the pig I'm gonna leave it up to you
guys because that's obviously yeah here
same with pigeons but there is issues as
far as getting pigeons oh yeah if you
guys knew nothing yeah we have a teacher
who grew up in a farm we got another guy
in Brooklyn we got it okay yeah all
right let's take care of that yeah
that's perfect yeah that's all I got all
right any questions yeah thanks man I'll
keep you guys updated too hey I
apologize
and all the commotion you know it's it's
uh it's not something that you know I'm
not like you guys want a bigger fish
yeah you know just some yeah yeah right
right I mean I don't need power to start
right now I don't know that's why I said
you deal with the cow right yes exactly
yeah yeah there were ten that were there
it sounds like like more than just those
10 all pull their money in to buy this
cow is what it sounds like or all these
animals and we ended up actually with a
pig and some other farm animals
yeah in in the school
but one of the I I didn't hear this but
the story as it was relayed to me is
that at least one of the kids said that
somebody in the administration a teacher
or somebody gave them a fob is the story
they're telling saying so they would
have access into the school so they're
going to do their own investigation on
that
and kind of yeah so there were I don't
know how many total were involved I mean
I only know about the 10 18 plus year
olds that were still there with a cow
you know like really right are we really
standing here dealing with this right
now I know I know I this is why I didn't
go like west of King County right you
didn't want to deal with it yes exactly
this is this I thought this was safe I
thought this was a safe distance from
farm animals to be honest I didn't I
didn't uh do the large animal unit no no
with the small animal right all right
right yeah I mean I'm used to the you
know the ankle biting Chihuahuas right
and the uh you know every now and then
the nuisance Pitbull
but yeah so
you know
all right these are these are literally
kids that are going to go to Harvard
that's that's the scary part about this
they're going to go out in the world we
put out a
our nixel social media thing okay it
says we're assisting now's police when
an animal complaint there's no immediate
you know right problem for the community
so mostly true
no no yeah I know we're gonna try to
quote
okay we're gonna try to push along the
fence and they just want to stand in
there to kind of
we just want to try to keep it in this
big Courtyard area right that's right
okay but hopefully we'll keep it against
the fence and it won't even notice in
the shoot until it already is okay
so all right we'll all stand down here
do we have enough people here now you
need me to call some more before okay
yeah yeah it's it's much more relaxed
than it had been
yeah
this rattle paddle
so she has to pull this way just shake
that thing okay
be the rattle panel person all right
thank you
a lot further down the cow line as it
were
outstanding
um
it's a bad spot it's a bad spot
[Music]
foreign
yeah John
[Music]
huh okay
so it had a ring or you put the ring
[Music]
all right
you took the worst of that yeah you did
the house 59 you can log one cow in
custody
all right
holy crap oh my god when that thing
turned right here do you see me
I was ready to go you're smarter than I
was heading towards you get out of here
that thing's gonna run me over well I
know you ran at me once yeah I guess all
right okay
all of us are okay I think the cow's
okay they actually put a ring in itself
clamp
all right all right thank you let's do
this let's get coffee yes let's get our
act together and then I'll call you here
in a little while okay yeah
aggravation by me to go through yeah me
too about an hour and a half to two
hours I'll reach out to you okay I'm
here till six all right all right all
right thank you guys okay yes
I know yeah this is a career story yeah
this doesn't happen every day I mean
thank God
really
thanks for sticking around
there we go oh there's another one
there's another one yeah
yeah
it's not fun though
[Music]
um
all right
I don't know if they got your
information but obviously we'll have to
get your information yeah they didn't
already uh I can't thank you enough
you know we don't want to see it hurt no
no
[Music]
right now
foreign
yes please and then we can uh discuss
how to take it off the trail that we can
discuss okay yes that sounds like a good
idea if you've got your ID I'll just
take a photo of it you bet that'll be
the easiest and your partner
sometimes you to offer though appreciate
it
all right thanks Serge I'm being
touching yes thank you guys appreciate
your help yeah yeah just make sure I can
see it
like
he needs your uh
cattle wrangling ID yeah
thank you
we'll get it out of here yeah and we're
gonna talk about what we're gonna do
all right I'm going to use
for both of you I'm going to use the
Wagner farmer dress not not your
personal address
um but we have to put your name and date
of birth yeah that you came unassisted
and boy was it an assist yeah I mean
that's the most impressive thing yeah
right I'm gonna oh Blake some donuts
at least at least I had a cow in a
headlock you know pretty much yeah
[Music]
okay A little beat up on itself
okay thank you very much both of you
some water yes yeah I'm sure that she's
looking for some rest yeah and use some
rest too all right thank you so let me
know what the status of the other
animals are
we don't
[Music]
thank you
anybody's name or can I just say so it's
Obama on the scene at this
Wagner I thought I've said some of them
okay I've got it the guy from Wagner
I'll give you his name okay actually
I'll text it too